let's start with a clip of Ted Cruz this
is Ted Cruz yesterday talking to
Department of Homeland and security
secretary Alejandro mayorkas over child
sex trafficking on the border and this
is something else what are these
wristbands
I don't know what they are you don't
know what they are
Mr secretary you've just testified to
the American people you're incompetent
at your job because I've been to the
southern border and if you go to the
southern border along the southern
border you see thousands of these
wristbands because the illegal
immigrants wear them the drug cartels
every color corresponds to how many
thousands of dollars they owe the
cartels you've turned these cartels into
multi-billion dollar criminal
organizations and these are modern day
leg irons because these are children
being sold into sex slavery and you
don't even know what they are that is
astonishing Mr secretary how many
children have been sold into sex slavery
under your Administration Senator we are
taking it to the cartel how many
children have been sold into sex slavery
do you know how many children have been
sold into sex slavery to an
unprecedented degree Mr secretary I want
to say to you right now it is your
behavior is disgraceful and the deaths
the children assaulted the children
raped they are at your feet and if you
had Integrity you would reside look I
mean I was pissed off
I was pissed off
a because I've seen too much of this I
mean I spend a lot of time on our
Southern border
I've seen too many of these children
who've been sexually abused and
brutalized I've seen the dead bodies on
our Southern border
and mayorkas has such utter contempt
that it was infuriating he refused to
answer even a single question the entire
hearing I mean you could ask him what
day it was and he wouldn't give you a
straight answer he was just he had his
talking points that's what he was going
to say
and you know his his crocodile tears his
empty expressions of empathy I I feel
for
the people who are dying of overdoses no
you don't if if you feel for them you
would stop doing what's causing it he's
the one who's opened up the Border
and the sad reality is the man doesn't
give a damn that a hundred thousand
people died of an overdose last year
because if he did he wouldn't preside
over a wide open border that is turning
the drug cartels into multi-billionaires
one more clip from the hearing yesterday
you were not thrilled with his sort of
stammering answers uh here we go has the
crisis at our Southern border
made Americans less safe yes or no
senator we are dedicated to the safety
has the crisis made Americans less safe
I don't I don't want a discourse it's a
yes or no question Senator we have a
challenge of you refuse to answer the
questions not SEC Mr secretary let me
show you how someone doing his job
answers a question in a straightforward
manner Chief Ortiz
is the crisis that is currently ongoing
at the southern border making the Border
less safe for Americans and Aliens alike
answer yes one word one syllable three
letters that's how someone answers a
question and does their job you're being
a politician misleading the American
people let me give you a chance again
will you show the same Integrity Chief
Ortiz shows is the crisis at the
southern border making Americans less
safe yes or no Senator we have 260
thousand he refused to answer the
question let's move on
[Music]
thank you